well a vicious ms-13 attack in New York
is being blamed on America's gaping
immigration loopholes Ramon our Avella
lopez and oscar Canales molina allegedly
took part in an ms-13 assault on to new
york high-school students both of the
alleged assailants were detained at the
border in 2016 but since they were
unaccompanied minors at the time they
were allowed to settle in this country
while awaiting deportation of course
they were never deported nobody ever is
without that catch and release policy
the crime likely wouldn't have happened
mark Morgan was head of the border
patrol under President Obama he was
dismissed by President Trump which you
should keep in mind as you listen to him
speak and he joins this night mr. Morgan
thanks very much for coming on tonight
so is it too much to say that this is a
real-world example of what can happen if
you have a dysfunctional immigration
policy
that's absolutely right Tucker and I
think you set a right is that it's about
that the immigration process in this
country across the board is bro this is
a great example American you know if
they could look this up the Flores
decision the Flores decision is what
mandates the United States border patrol
to release minor children they only have
a few amount of days and once they hit
that they've got to release them
regardless if they've been properly
vetted regards that they have a parent
in the United States they have to be
released into the interior United States
and so that's a judicial ruling the
court came up with that decision could
has Congress ever acted on it I mean
since clearly that's crazy
why doesn't the United States Congress
fix it that's a great question Tucker
another reason why I'm breaking my
silence because Congress could fix this
in five minutes if they wanted to before
I was a chief of Border Patrol I was
with the FBI and I actually supervised
an ms-13 gang force in Southern
California we used to catch him on
surveillance wires and they would laugh
unless thirteen gang members would laugh
how easy it was to go back and forth
between the Mexico and US border so
we've had a number debates on this show
with Democrats who say there's something
bigoted about criticizing ms-13 as
someone who's actually worked apprehend
ms-13 how would you respond to that
that's ridiculous ms-13 and and I know
this may be controversial but were the
the president referred to them as
animals I absolutely said that is
correct
those ms-13 members and I can tell you
again because I've worked it and not
been there as a chief I've been the
detention facilities where I've walked
up to these individuals that are
so-called miners 17 or under and I've
looked at him and I've looked at their
eyes Tucker and I said that is a
soon-to-be ms-13 gang member
it's unequivocal and they're their
victims are overwhelmingly immigrants
themselves right that's that's another
untold story Tucker that I'm glad you're
talking about tonight that's absolutely
correct
that's another incredulous thing they
absolutely prey on their own right so if
you if you cared you would care about
that mr. Morgan thank you very much mark
Morgan great to see you you bet